bluh Archer asked if you could create or
teach your own college or high school
course what would the name of the class
be and how would you teach it this is a
great question first of all this is
really fun like I thought all the
Instagram photos were just going to be
somebody holding up a sign like the
rules
I didn't realize so many people you like
that'll jab on the rules
I didn't by the way vaynernation you're
not following the rules like the whole
like sign thing is not happening but
let's do it over time here's how you get
your answer but obviously because some
of you are getting through with your non
following the rules answers you guys are
all going to continue to do this but the
whole like imposing me into the photo is
phenomenal didn't see that coming good
job with you guys ah my course would be
called oh my god this is such a funny
thing I mean my course would literally
be called why you shouldn't have signed
up for this course in the first place
taught by Gary Vaynerchuk and it would
talk about the disconnect between where
school is and where the real world is
right now how I would try to teach more
than anything for people not to take my
words and try to regurgitate them look
it's almost what I'm trying to mean I'm
teaching my course right now with
askgaryvee my big thing here guys is and
I and I razz the vaynernation once in a
while so in this short episode it feels
appropriate way to many of you are just
regurgitating what I'm saying instead of
actually doing it boy do I love all of
you that hearted up my hustle picture on
Instagram the other day let's put that
up and then when I looked at like 7 or 8
people to just see how they were
hustling cuz I keep doing it I keep
internation understand one thing I take
enormous pride and double checking your
actions while you regurgitate my
hyperbole let me tell you why it's not
cuz I'm the best dude ever it's because
if my fans that spew my stuff aren't
actually acting on my recommendation
which is putting in the work doing the
right things listening to their audience
working hustling trying doing the right
practices not automating well then when
people like if you post a photo on
regrain
I'm in and like hustle but you're
playing you know called duty of duty all
day then that all your friends on
Instagram the 97 people like well that's
just a guy that spews hyperbole because
if you love him so much but you aren't
doing it well then that just disconnects
so one of the main reasons I'm paying
attention to what everybody's doing is
because if the people that are consuming
my content and retweeting and pushing
out my stuff are not acting on that
behavior that has a chance of hurting me
you know fun it's been over the last
four or five months because of this show
because of the zinging that you many of
the people that have commented on every
episode have emailed me and said you
know what I haven't actually been doing
it like I'm talking the talk but I'm not
walking the walk that's been really fun
for me to watch and so I forgot the
question
it's the course right I mean look the
course would be like listen to
everything I'm going to tell you about
the disconnect between school and the
real world from a marketing business
standpoint I know you could be a lawyer
or doctor you need to learn that stuff I
respect that but from like entrepreneur
business stuff and the whole course
would be 8 to 12 weeks of me pounding
you not to regurgitate my information
but to act on it over here I'm over here
now Dirac you need to act on it you need
to actually execute you can't say hustle
and then not hustle you can't say and
this is the hustle part a lot of you are
doing here's the part that really pisses
me off all of you that retweeted my
whole listen to people instead of just
talk anything engage right and the other
thing is a lot of you are engaging with
each other which is great I love that
like 20 of you have become really good
friends and retweet each other and hard
everything but go out there new search
on Twitter right try different things go
right meet our articles on medium I
can't believe how many of them you are
not writing articles on medium the one
platform that rewards virality to people
that have no audience the far majority
of you you should be what we're hustling
medium every day and I have awareness
because it's giving me more free
awareness guys medium is a platform that
allows you if you write a good story for
one of their editors to put on the home
page and all of a sudden you've got a
platform and a couple of you've done it
and we've pounded it here and you see me
doing it that's the part that pisses me
off you see me doing it heavy
plenty of ubasti hey askgaryvee why do
you post up on medium and not your own
blog because it brings me just so
everybody understands I will never do
anything if it doesn't bring me either
short-term or long-term value so if I'm
doing it don't you think you should be
paying attention a little more that why
and so my course would be very pretty
bring you back my course will be very
predicated on here's all the advice but
please don't be a student be a
practitioner